what do you think happens in a
relationship when
the woman out earns what the man earns
uh it's gonna end in divorce more than
likely so there's a study conducted uh
by american psychologists and they found
that if a woman out earned her husband
it was likely it was 50 likely that the
marriage would end in divorce in fact
this was corroborated by studies done by
finnish data scientists or
finnish
psychologists as well as swedish
psychologists
and it's interesting because the swedish
psychologist found that if a woman
brought in 80 of the total household
income
there was a
the likelihood of divorce increased by a
factor of two uh relative to if a one
woman brought in let's say 20 percent of
the total household income
wow
okay
so you said
so don't don't all relationships have a
50 chance of ending in divorce
yeah that's what that's what everyone
says or at least that's that's the uh
the idea out there uh i don't know how
well that statistic is stress tested
because
it's i think it's contingent on a lot of
factors so economics is a big one during
periods of depression people people are
economic downturn people typically don't
get divorced and typically stick
together because it's very costly
um
and as well you know there's a lot of
mediating factors that that um
that
allow divorce to happen or make it more
likely to happen but economics is a
massive factor
specifically economics as in the wife
making more than the husband
so what's the solution there
i don't think there is a solution i
think that people should probably lower
their expectations and
in terms of in terms of understanding
that okay well this person is the
breadwinner and it's probably
whether or not it's a matter of the
woman that person is the breadwinner
it's just it's it's it's how the
situation is and one should probably
temper their expectations about that
okay that makes sense are there tricks
that you've heard of that you can do to
offset that so if you are the
breadwinner in a family and you're the
female is there something you can do to
offset the fact because it must be it
must have something to do with dominance
right you don't want to be maybe you
don't want to be the dominant person in
the relationship yeah yeah i think
it it's again it probably goes back to
roles played in relationships it's it's
not always the case that the man is the
breadwinner it's sometimes the case that
the woman is more dominant and she is
she's uh she is the breadwinner and so
it probably comes down to being able to
to met out responsibilities on the part
of both sexes and sometimes the man
stays home and takes care of children
and sometimes the woman goes out there
and earns you know earns the money and
so it probably is contingent on both
partners understanding that this is the
role that is played
okay
that makes sense
or they're just
doomed they're just doomed yeah
um
okay
you've you've talked about
dark gentlemen
what what does what does that mean
what's a dark gentleman so a dark
gentleman is a term that i've
sort of coined to
describe the the perfect man as it were
or the man that is the most attractive
and the dark gentleman is a combination
of
a man that is able to provide 3p so he's
able to protect uh provide as in you
know economic provision and parentally
invest but at the same time he does have
those dark triad characteristics which
makes him very attractive so he threads
the line between the perfect gentleman
and that uh dark triad personality so
he's able to combine those two aspects
which are held in logical contrast so i
i refer to it as the unity of
contradictions it's actually very
similar to
when your dad speaks about um chaos and
order i think he
the point that jordan is trying to get
across here is that you need a
combination of the two you need some
sort of golden mean as it were you can't
have too much order you can't have too
much chaos because in both situations
you get totalitarianism
yeah that makes sense
so that would be i feel like the dark
triad too can you can you list off what
those characteristics are absolutely so
the dark triad are three personality
traits that are found in individuals so
you have machiavellianism which is
typically described as sort of
manipulation or the ability to
manipulate uh the second is narcissism
you know pretty straightforward and uh
the third is psychopathy so callousness
lying thrill-seeking so it's said by
psychologists that these three traits
are quite negative so individuals that
possess these traits are dark right
they're very
um negative individuals
yeah okay
and so
but for some reason they're attractive
to women yeah exactly that so these are
evil but attractive yeah very very
attractive so these these individuals
it's important to keep in mind that
they're very low in neuroticism they're
very high in openness they're very low
in conscientiousness they're very high
in extroversion and
those characteristics on their own are
pretty attractive so a narcissist is you
know smile speaks nicely wears very nice
clothes you know that in and of itself
is pretty attractive to women right a
person that is machiavellian
is very disagreeable and what the
statistics indicate is that an
individual that is highly disagreeable
if if they
are below the the mean level of
disagreeability they typically make 18.3
more um in in terms of yearly yearly
income and that translates to about nine
thousand seven hundred and twenty two
dollars per year
wow
how much of that is behind the the wage
gap
a lot a lot so
uh you know
i think agreeableness has to do quite a
bit with why some women don't advance as
far as they do in their in their fields
in their respective fields what men are
on average more discriminable than women
so they're more likely to fight for a
wage increase they're more than likely
to fight for
um a promotion
and so
these are this specific factor explains
why men typically you know earn women on
top of the fact that you know there's a
whole number of factors including
differences in in work and job type
occupation in in industry in schooling
in the amount of hours worked the level
of danger of the job itself it's one
factor among many i think
yeah that makes sense i didn't i've
always been like fairly have you ever
done my dad's personality test just out
of curiosity i have done a personality
test actually yes but not you have yeah
not quite your dad's
which one did you do i don't remember
but i do have it saved on my phone i
have the results saved somewhere
just from working for my dad and trying
to run a business and everything i've
had to kind of force myself into
uncomfortable positions and then you get
used to it right asking for more as a
woman
but i think a trick
for doing that is the worst thing that
can happen like
just to give you my experience of like
trying to ask for more money or
something it's like i get these like
feelings of guilt and of like do i
deserve it am i doing enough like this
kind of thing even if kind of logically
i can say okay well if this makes sense
but it's like this guilt horror feeling
for asking for more whereas if i talk to
like disagreeable men like
they're okay with asking for more even
if they don't necessarily think they
deserve it they're like i'm just gonna
see what happens they're like well the
worst thing that could happen is they
say no yes so if you think about it that
way it's like what's gonna happen if you
ask for a raise they're gonna say no
like that's not that big a deal but the
feeling inside is like angst and horror
yes i think as a
female maybe at least me sometimes yeah
i i think i think a lot of women do have
that that specific experience i think a
lot of men are more comfortable asking
for a raise
uh
and you're right it's all it's all a
matter of opportunity and just taking
risks i think
a lot of the scientific literature would
indicate that women are more risk averse
than men men are typically the ones that
you know we talk about job type
occupation
they're typically the ones that do very
dangerous jobs right your your your data
will speak about um you know people that
work on oil rigs out in uh you know
various parts of the world specifically
in alberta and that's not that's not a
very safe job right it's quite dangerous
and yeah it takes a lot of cajones to do
a job like that you have to be quite um
interested in risk or or very risk
oriented as it were
oh yeah that's for sure i've got cousins
who work on oil raised they're like
they're crazy people lose arms on those
things it's crazy yeah
uh yeah
okay
okay i've got some more questions from
things you've written ooh okay let's
talk about this one this is fun um
why are smart women less likely to get
married
people above a certain iq that's a good
question so there was a study i'll add a
bit of context here so there's a study
that was conducted by four universities
here in the uk and it was on
um marriage and the role played by iq or
iq affects uh marriage and what the
study found was that every 16 point
increase in a man's iq increases his
odds of marriage or his likelihood of
marriage by 35 percent
in contrast every 16 point increase in a
woman's iq decreases her odds of
marriage by 40
so you can see here that there's a
staggering imbalance right
and 40 percent 40 a whopping 40
per 16 point increase
has there i do do you know if there have
ever been any studies on like do men say
you get somebody with a 130 i have a 135
iq as a male
do we know the average iq they're
marrying like they can't be skewing
towards 100 right wouldn't you just get
honestly wouldn't there be a
communication issue if there's a two
standard deviation difference in iq yeah
more than likely more than likely i
don't know of any studies that would
indicate that but i think going back to
your original question as to why women
have
an issue particularly women within hike
you have an issue getting married is
that
they're looking for a person on their
same
iq level their same their same
intellectual level and it's really hard
to find someone with that high of an iq
and these individuals are typically
probably in a lab somewhere or already
married and
for men as well i think a lot of guys
have an ego and they want to seem like
the smarter one in a relationship right
they want to see seem the most dominant
one and i think they're
they're they're put upon or they're
they're turned off by a woman that is
very smart right it's very it's very
emasculating yep that makes sense
oh that mean that makes sense
fewer people out there and yeah
i mean i understand that i don't think
i'd want to be with somebody who i
thought was
dumber than me honestly be more
attractive if they're smarter than me
smarter than me like oh i didn't think
of that that's fun instead of being like
i've already thought of that
but thank you yeah
yeah i think you need a balance right i
think you need someone that is able to
sort of pick up the slack so there's
certain things that i don't know that i
would you know i love that my partner
knows and uh
in the opposite right i think yeah it's
that it's that balance as well that
you're able to balance one another
although i did have a friend and he
would always say that he had a very high
iq it was like 150 or something he would
say to me or i would ask him you know if
he did it with 100 iq wouldn't as you
said wouldn't there be a communication
issue and he i think he said very
callously i have enough intelligence for
both of us and i said all right
interesting
okay i mean i can see that too i think
it's probably dependent on personality
too i'm sure some people like maybe your
friend was just like it doesn't matter i
got it
i have enough iq my brain is good enough
for both of us yeah fair uh that's good
okay
well on on this point as well michaela i
just want to say that it it's also
down to preferences as well is that
women typically look for men who are
much smarter than they are right they
you know in terms of attractiveness the
two greatest predictors of a male
attraction as in female females being
attracted to males are educational
attainment and income and that's not the
same for males right the two
characteristics that males typically
typically look for are
youth and fertility
yes harsh but true harsh for true
harsh but true
okay you said in an article
it's from my list of questions that
there's a disconnect between what women
want and what's actually available to
them
why do you think that is
um
it's it's a good it's a good question
and i think it's not just women i think
it's just it's just people in general
there's a level of entitlement that a
lot of people have
and what you think you get is not often
what you get in reality so a woman that
is highly educated woman that makes
quite a bit of money
uh on a yearly basis
you know she she in her mind and
probably rightly so deserves a partner
that that makes quite a bit of money and
has an equal level of education but the
trouble with that is that there are few
men who fit that certain category who
fit that criteria who can reach that
certain level and he is most likely
interested in a woman that is much
younger so although
you know the one feels that she can
attain this partner it's probably not
the case that she will be able to do so
so it's it's again it's that disconnect
between reality and perception
hmm
i bet you make a lot of people unhappy
yeah i don't know i think
maybe my writing makes people
uncomfortable but i think on a daily
basis i uh i get on pretty well with
people
sometimes have have you gotten any
backlash for anything you've written
yeah i got a couple of mean emails i
think
one one of my friends was very upset
with me but you know i just had to
explain to her that these are just facts
you know it's i look i'm just recording
this stuff right i'm not i'm not trying
to like can i can i swear on your
podcast yeah yeah yeah i'm look i'm not
trying to [ __ ] on you i'm not trying to
ruin your day or anything
this is just what the numbers indicate
and
it is what it is right